we can all feel for multi-millionaire
businessman Richard Mason when he
discovered that the three boys he had
always thought were his biological sons
were in fact fathered by another man but
having discovered this what was the
point in him chasing his ex-wife through
the courts for money
he didn't need claiming alleged
paternity fraud in the end she gave him
250,000 pounds back from a four-million
divorce settlement
to avoid having to name the boy's
biological father in court the story has
been all over the papers this week
according to the reports the boys don't
want to know who their biological father
is they see mr. Mason as their father
and they are right forget about the
genetics mr. Mason is the boy's father
he brought them up from when they were
born and surely that's what matters
some things are better kept private just
if some because so many other things
have been going on this week Craig I'm
sure you'll agree just to fill the
viewers in on some of the background
Richard Mason was the co-founder of
money supermarket commies thought as you
said he was the father of three now
grown-up sons in 2016 he was told he'd
been infertile since birth it turns out
his sons have been fathered by an
unknown man with whom his ex-wife had an
affair believed have been working in the
same same organization before this
emerged mr. Mason paid his wife four
million 4xy four million in a divorce
several and as you rightly said great he
recently sued her for paternity fraud
she paid him two hundred and fifty
thousand pounds in an out-of-court in in
order to keep the identity of the boy's
biological father secret with the
exception of the young men involved no
one emerges from this with any credit at
all do they really um and I hear what
you say and it never falls to anyone to
tell anyone else how to parent because
it is a unique experience and I would
never tell him um how to be a mom or a
dad to me or dad but I do kind of get
how he feels and you're right he is
effectively the father just as if he had
adopted them and there are many people
watching the show who will have been
adopted or who are adoptive parents and
it's a fantastic scene to take on but I
do understand his to use her lovely
French word he's only his anger his and
I understand that having paid a chunk of
money and yes he is a wealthy man but
that
doesn't mean that he shouldn't
necessarily have recourse to law I can
understand why he's almost grieving
because what he thought he had he didn't
have but I say again great apart from
the young men involved no one emerges
with credit but surely in those
circumstances you think twice then you
think three times and then before you
start taking action because in the end
these were his kids
they weren't genetically emotionally but
not yet I think they're two separate
issues I think how he feels about the
children is one thing how he feels about
the way his wife behaved ex wife behaved
is another thing so as a man he's
furious at her and the only way to get
back at her the only way to feel that
there was some justice in this is the
course he took that doesn't change how
yes that's what it is
I mean it turned everything what I'm
saying is but look suddenly these boys
know their name they're it's all over
the papers all think this didn't have to
come out what's the advantage of it
there's an interesting quote here from
Sir James Mumby who is the former
president of the High Court family
division and he says the modern British
family is complex and take an almost
infinite variety of forms children live
in households where their parents may be
married or unmarried they may be brought
up by a single parent by two parents or
even by three parents and it seems to me
that's the world we live in
yeah yeah no it is a decision it was a
deceit by that of by the wife of the
husband wife but how much damage yes
because I had to know how much damage
has it done to his relationship with
those boys there's a there's a quote
here because according to it depends
what you believe apparently a couple of
the kids no longer talk to him and you
says if I could wave a magic wand I
would want to be in all of their lives
which I just think it's really sad and
I'm going through in my personal life of
which I'm not sure I see where
well as you may have noticed I'm going
through a really complex decision
process at the moment because I don't
have a partner on I want to be a mom so
I'm going through the process of looking
at spend a sperm donor conception and in
this country there is a law where when
the children get to 18 they have the
legal right to act as those various
identifying information about the father
and if the father wants to know yes so
in this country when you do a donor you
have to you log identifying information
and non-identifying information when the
child reaches 16 and 18 depending on the
differences of the the information your
child has a right to find out
essentially who their father is and for
me in personal choice we're not in this
current before you could lock yeah not
in this country not as a donor
so anyway yeah it has and for me
personally I'm in this really complex
situation because I wouldn't regard the
donor as my children's father and I
would always be very honest with my
child and tell them you know you were a
gift and I've been challenged by a
couple of members of my own family
because what Matt what I was intending
to do for my own selfish reasons was go
and get my my sperm got it's unlawful
but the sperm from a different country
maybe Cyprus or somewhere where that
rule doesn't exist so that I didn't have
this complexity within my own family
18 years down the line and I've been
challenged actually within my family
environment and saying well actually is
that fair to the children and I'm not
sure the aunt I was reading I was
reading the story about this family
where a woman did that on her own she
got she and conceived a child through a
sperm donor and they never got contact
with the [ __ ] that the donor with the
four other but all of the different
children have been conceived with his
sperm got to know each other and all the
different women and they all became a
weird blended family through the kite
they were all the siblings and they just
look they go on a holiday together yeah
they're not sure I would I don't think
that's what any of them set out to do
but you know that I mean coming to grace
point that is the nature of modern
families that's what the key point in it
for me that I wanted to land is honesty
so I would always always be honest to my
children about the situation this is
where but it's much easier to be honest
when you've got one child in you I
wouldn't have just
when I was a law student I thought I
thought about doing family law and I've
been in court before mr. justice mummy
he's very very good family lawyer hmm
and became a very eminent family judge
and the reason I decided not to do
family law is because it is so arguments
over a children and and parental
arrangements are they're just the most
intractable because because people have
been in these marriages and it when it
breaks down there is nothing like the
venom and the vitriol and the revenge
that makes and they do and it's tragic
to see but this is like oh do you know
what there are two that I think there
are two different trends in the way our
families are going so on the one hand we
have more blended families actually I've
got a stat here that in 2017 there were
twelve point nine million families where
both parents were natural parents in the
UK there were 3.3 million with one
natural parent of one step parent there
are two point eight million lone parent
families and there were ten thousand
families with same-sex couples so the
nature's of families are changing but
the other trend is this obsession with
our heritage in our DNA look how many
people want to know ancestry the Grand
Prince their ancestors and I think that
people do have a desire to know so if
you were to Michelle can see the child
through a sperm donor there would be a
very high chance that your child would
really want to know who that person is
and they'd want to know not just who the
donor was but she lied that's the
problem it's a complex issue I'm sure we
wish everybody involved the best